hey how's it going bros my name is fanny
pack today we're playing a half-life mod
called glitch life it basically takes
the game randomized cystic textures the
models the sounds and a bunch of crap
that I don't know what it is and out
comes this we have to do the crap jobs
okay here we go
this looks great
ya know this this is just how I remember
half-life my favorite game oh god oh
fellow soldier now let's see if you can
do the same at extreme line my god oh
I'm playing now okay great
where am i oh my god this is terrifying
half-life uh knack on LSD okay this is
my gun
great gun my god
what is that thing in my [ __ ] there's
definitely something inside me you see
that there's a fish inside why is there
a fish in my butthole fish get out of
that fish god damn it don't you just
hate when fishes get inside you there we
go look at my [ __ ] gun what is that
I'm walking through there what just
happened of course it's safety hood what
hi guys oh my god I'm so sorry people
what are you doing you're following me
aren't you
stop stop dumbest [ __ ] scare the [ __ ]
out of me hey man what do you have to
all right this is literally half life
when drunk
this is gonna chair this gun is a chair
take this share [ __ ] that's right
don't [ __ ] with a share of what is this
oh cool
nice gun it's a guy sitting on my
shoulder fantastic okay here we are
again I'm a I'm a plant love being a
plant live in that plant life it really
fits cuz this game really feels like
drugs best grenade ever becomes the
[ __ ] yes oh my god
now we're really talking drugs what's
that what am I am I am I a stone I'm a
stone god I love how god oh my god oh my
god
calm down there I'm a stone so creepy
throwing like my goats there you go go
go
oh I became a pineapple I am now a
pineapple throw go pineapples jesus
[ __ ] christ the pineapples are strong
what the [ __ ] is this what am i throw my
grenades are giant aliens no big deal
alien motherships best kind of grenades
oh my god go my grenade friend
go best soundtrack ever is that what is
that it's my rocket launcher is
helicopters yes that's yes of course
oh god I don't think I'm supposed to go
down there I choose you
pick it to you
got pick at you no no it crashed
god dammit alright I could play this for
so long but it's so much fun I'm gonna
have to end up so there if you enjoy
watching leave a like I'll leave a link
to download this in the description it's
really fun if you have half-life I
definitely recommend checking out this
mod that's always think it was so much
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video as always stay awesome bros
the naval juice is not resurrecting him
let's ask more general people of this
city holy [ __ ] why are you riding